foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar current
state of pharmacogenomics and its future
I'm Christy Jewel of Labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar has been
organized by Thermo Fisher Scientific
using the Labyrinth platform to learn
more about Thermo Fisher Scientifics
products and services please visit their
website at thermofisher.com
now as a reminder today's webinar is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
icon on the far left of your screen to
obtain your credits
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
also if you experience any technical
questions you can utilize this QA box
and we will assist you directly
I'd like to now cordially welcome
today's speaker Dr Ray Lorenz director
Medical Science liaison neurology and
pharmacogenomics in the division of
medical Affairs at Quest Diagnostics
for a complete biography of Dr Lorenz
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome Dr Lorenz the floor is yours
thank you Christy for that introduction
I really appreciate it uh as she said we
are going to talk about pharmacogenomics
what it looks like today and then what
it hopefully will look like in the
future
first I'd like to start with my
disclosure slide
before you go
and then I want to go through our agenda
for the day so first I'd really like to
review our recent pharmacogenomic
guidelines that have been published by
the cpic organization and then secondly
I'd like to go through some of the
literature that's out there regarding
mental health and polypharmacy utility
of pharmacogenomics and then finally I'd
like to kind of discuss some of the
barriers that we see currently in
pharmacogenomic adoption and ways to
hopefully counter those
but first I'd like to talk a little bit
about what pharmacogenomics is
pharmacogenomics is the science of using
somebody's genetics to help pick
medications or medication doses for them
a little better there is lots of
literature out there to support the fact
that genetic variations do impact how
patients respond to medications and so
we do have guidelines that can help us
to teach us how to use those Gene drug
interactions for our patients
so where does pharmacogenomics fit when
we talk about kind of the landscape of
clinical practice well we have two kind
of things that are going on right now we
have pharmacokinetics which is how the
body affects the medication so really
here we're talking about metabolism and
then we have how the medication affects
the body which is called
pharmacodynamics which really has to do
with receptors or Transporters and not
so much metabolism there and then
pharmacogenomics can tell you tell us
how pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics interact in a specific
patient to help us pick medications
better for that patient
one thing I always like to point out
though is that pharmacogenomics is never
used in a vacuum it's never used by
itself it is just a tool that we can use
in combination with lots of other
patient and societal related factors to
help us pick that medication better for
a patient so we're not throwing away all
of the stuff we learned in school about
how to treat our patients we're using
pharmacogenomics to supplement that
information and you can see lots of the
different ways that we choose
medications for patients and all the
different factors that go into that but
one thing I always like to mention here
is that pharmacogenomics is
um
like trying to figure out how
we interact with all of these different
pieces and when we're picking a
medication for a patient a lot of times
we're trying to think of it as finding a
needle in a haystack and what
pharmacogenomics does is it doesn't tell
you exactly where the needle is but it
does remove some of the hay so that's a
little easier to find that specific
medication or that needle
why is this important well because
adverse drug reactions account for a lot
of different uh societal issues we have
emergency department visits that are
involved here and then also fatalities
over a hundred thousand fatalities every
year
um due to drug interaction or drug
reactions so by using patients genetics
we can help improve the effectiveness
and decrease the side effect profile for
our patients one thing I do like to
point out here is that
we know that not all patients respond
the same to all medications right and so
what pharmacogenomics does is it can
help us parse out which patients are
going to benefit from a medication which
patients are not going to benefit from
that medication or which patients are
going to have side effects to a medicine
and which ones won't
so how does pharmacogenomics work well
first we would take a sample from a
patient either that's blood saliva or a
buccal swab and we use that genetic
material to genotype that patient and at
Quest We Do It for 44 different genes
and that includes hundreds of different
alleles here and those 44 genes are ones
that are potentially important for
medication therapy
uh the results are then presented in a
report that describes the genotype the
phenotype and then which alleles we're
testing
one interesting thing about Quest report
is that we do not include medication
guidance on our report so we want to
make sure that we're leaving the
clinician to practice medicine and that
not something the lab is doing but the
good thing about our results is that
they can be used in clinical decision
support systems or electronic medical
records that are set up to receive these
this discrete data to help guide the
medication selection using those systems
and then with the cdss and EMR uses
various published literature guidelines
product labels and the fda's table of
pharmacogenetic associations to generate
Gene drug information and then
pharmacists or other Healthcare
professionals can review these
recommendations to help us pick
medications a little better for our
patients
I do want to go over some terminology
really quickly here when we talk about
some of these pharmacokinetic genes and
pharmacokinetic phenotypes I'll talk a
lot about metabolism and one thing I
like to joke about is that metabolism is
not how quickly we break down our food
uh in this context at least we're really
talking about here how our bodies break
down the medications specifically one
other thing I'll mention is that there
is a concept of what we call
phenoconversion which is where we have
drug interactions that are increasing or
decreasing the activity of these enzymes
beyond what our genetics say that it
should be and that's called drug drug
Gene interactions and so we have four
kind of categories of phenotypes
possible for patients that do the
pharmacogenetic testing
so first we have normal and so that's
normal metabolism it means that there is
a normal amount of parent medication and
metabolite available in that patient's
body and then all the way to one end we
have poor metabolizers and so poor
metabolizers have little to no
metabolism going on through that pathway
in in their liver and then which means
that we're going to have a lot more of
the parent drug and a lot less of any
metabolites that are created from the
metabolism and then on the other end of
the spectrum we have Ultra rapid
metabolism which means that patients are
breaking down these medications that go
through that specific pathway very very
quickly and we have a lot of metabolites
available but not a lot of the parent
compound available for action in the
body
so I'd like to go through some of the
more recent guidelines from cpic I'll
talk about what cpic is or who cpic is
and then we can talk about kind of some
of the more recent guidance that has
come out from from cpic
so cpic is the clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation Consortium and that's a
mouthful which is why I'll continue to
just call it cpic
um
cpic has a standard system for grading
levels of evidence for Gene drug
pairings and uses this to present
guidelines for clinicians to use they do
genotype to phenotype conversions so
what is your gened genes say over to
what does your phenotype look like
whether it's a fast metabolizer slow
metabolizer that kind of thing and then
they also link those phenotypes if a
patient's you know poor metabolizer what
happens to to the medications there do
we need to adjust the doses should we
not use it that kind of thing so that's
really what we're talking about here
we're talking about linking phenotypes
to prescribing recommendations the big
thing here though is I want to make sure
to mention that the guidelines don't
provide information on who to test which
patients need to be tested or should be
tested only what to do if the
pharmacogenomic results are already
available
the great thing about cpic is that the
guidelines are published and freely
available on their website and that's
right there for you the
cpicpgx.org
and so all of the guidelines that are
published are published in peer review
journals and they're available for
anybody to look up on their website
so I'm going to look at four of the new
guidelines or updates that have been
created for pharmacogenomics with cpic
first we'll take a look at Clopidogrel
or Plavix with
cyp2c19 we'll look at some of the
opioids and cyp 2d6 we'll look at
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase or
G6PD and then we'll also find a look at
statins and slco1b1
so the clopidical guidelines have been
recently updated they were done in late
20 teens and then were recently updated
this last year Clopidogrel is an
anti-platelet agent that is used often
for cardiovascular or cerebrovascular
indications and then
uh interesting thing here is that it's a
pro drug that is converted primarily by
cyp 2c19 to its active metabolite so
Clopidogrel itself is not active it
doesn't do anything to inhibit platelet
aggregation but only attack and its
active metabolite is the one that
actually is doing the work here so if
you are a patient that does not have a
good metabolism through cyp 2c19 such as
a poor or intermediate metabolizer those
patients when they receive Clopidogrel
have been shown to be at an increased
risk of potential cardiovascular events
or Strokes beyond what they've already
had because most of the time we're using
these after a heart attack or a stroke
so the recommendations in the CPA
guidelines include choosing an
alternative platelet agent for those
patients that have had acute coronary
syndrome or and or percutaneous coronary
intervention or PCI one interesting
thing to note here is that press sugrel
is actually contracted contraindicated
in patients that have a stroke so you
couldn't wouldn't want to use that for
those types of patients one other thing
that has been shown recently in the
literature that cpic made to to mention
was that using higher doses of
Clopidogrel in an attempt to try to
increase the amount of metabolite that's
available in those poor metabolizers
doesn't really show any benefits so
increasing the dose for Clopidogrel in
this in this context isn't really going
to to do much for that patient it's
really best to switch to a different
agent if you're going to be using or
going to a meeting platelet inhibition
for intermediate report metabolizers at
2c19
next I'd like to talk a little bit about
the opioids and cyp 2d6 Tramadol and
codeine are two big ones that are
primarily metabolized by cyp 2d6 and so
codeine and tramadol are active parent
entities but through metabolism by 2d6
they're converted to even more active
metabolites almost like Pro drugs but
not quite because the parents are active
so here we have the pro the active
metabolite for Tramadol is called odess
methyl Tramadol and then morphine is
actually produced from from codeine by
2d6
so the issue here is that patients who
are Ultra rapid metabolizers at cyp 2d6
can become very quickly toxic on these
medications with these active
metabolites and have really bad side
effects such as respiratory depression
and then poor metabolizers because
they're not getting a lot of that active
metabolite are not going to potentially
achieve their therapeutic benefit which
would be you know pain control in this
in this case
so the recommendations from cpic are to
avoid using these medications and or
Ultra rapid metabolizers and then in
intermediate metabolizers the avoidance
of these medications is optional and
using potentially something other uh the
in the opiate class if those are needed
that is not metabolized by cyp 2d6
something like morphine or hydromorphone
next we can talk a little bit about
hydrocodone and oxycodone both of those
are also metabolized by cyp2d6 but to
not as great a degree as they are for
Cy for the tramadolin codeine and so
when you look at the cpic guidelines
they mentioned that only hydrocodone
really has optional guidance for
intermediate report metabolizers to
avoid it and that oxycodone specifically
was not
mentioned as far as needing dose of
judgment dose adjustments or avoiding it
in 2d6 poor intermediate metabolizers
the guidelines also reviewed to
pharmacodynamic genes which one is oprm1
which is the MU opiate receptor Gene and
comt which is the catechol O methyl
transferase Gene but there was not
enough evidence according to cpic to
make any clinical recommendations based
on these pharmacodynamic genes so I'm
sure that there'll be more to come with
that in the future when as we kind of
learn more about how these
pharmacodynamic Gene changes can affect
patients requirement for pain control
uh glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase or
G6PD also has a recently updated
guidelines and so patients who are
deficient at this enzyme have an
increased risk for acute hemolytic
anemia
which is
um you know potentially a problem
obviously for those patients and is a
really big issue when you have a patient
is stressed and by stress quote unquote
we mean anything that is kind of
altering the the body and so here
um in this case it can be caused by
specifically medications
the patients most likely to have G6PD
issues are Asian or African ancestry but
it can happen in any in anybody and so
the guidelines do recommend using the
genotype but also looking at the G6PD
activity using various phenotyping
methods there
the guidelines do classify medication as
high medium or low risk and you can see
there on the slide kind of how those
break down most of the medications that
had been previously thought to be a
really huge issue with G6PD have been
kind of reclassified as lower risk now
and so but I had the list there for you
guys to look through
finally for the guidelines section here
I'd like to talk a little bit about the
statins and slc-01b1
hmg-coa reductase Inhibitors or statins
are used to treat high cholesterol and
so this
slc-01b1 Gene makes a protein that
facilitates the Statin uptake into the
liver and so patients that have a
decreased function here are at a higher
risk of what is considered
statin-associated musculoskeletal
symptoms or I like to say just kind of
myopathy and so if you have a decreased
function here you are at a higher
potential potentially high risk for that
myopathy
and then there are two additional genes
that are mentioned in the guidelines for
other specific medications
that you can kind of look through there
the final I'd like to say that there is
a algorithm in the guidelines that are
based on
slco1b1 activity and the level of
intensity of the satins with their High
moderate or low and that can help to
reduce the risk of Sams so if a patient
has this kind of decreased function at
the slc-01b1 gene it doesn't mean that
they can't take statins it just means
that we may have to kind of looking and
look at the dosing a little bit more
closely
so after reviewing some of those
guidelines I'd like to kind of talk a
little bit more about how we use
pharmacogenomics now um in in the clinic
and most often I see it being used in
mental health circumstances and so I'll
do a little bit of a brief literature
review looking at kind of the data
that's out there looking uh at this the
mental health indications for
pharmacogenomics
the first study that I'd like to talk
about here um was a study that looked at
a few hundred patients and looked at
patients that were receiving
pharmacogenomic guidance by their
providers versus those that weren't
which is called treatment as usual and
what they saw in this study was that
remission rates after 12 weeks were more
than doubled when you used
pharmacogenomics versus when you did not
and that the number needed to treat for
one additional patient to benefit from
pharmacogenomic testing if they have
severe depression is three and so for me
that's a pretty low number needed to
treat especially when we think about how
never needed numbers needed to treat for
antidepressants in general are about a
lot higher than that and so for me this
was a really good study that kind of
talked about how we can use
pharmacogenomics for our patients that
are severely depressed
another study is called the guided study
this is a very large blinded
placebo-controlled eight-week study in
outpatients that all had treatment
resistant depression
and so again they looked at patients
that had been there whose clinicians
were Guided by the pharmacogenomics or
PGX and then treatment as usual or Tau
after the eight weeks there was no
difference in the symptom Improvement on
the handy scale between the two arms
however there were significant
differences in response rates and
remission rates in favor of
pharmacogenomics
and the other thing for me I think that
really kind of drives home the the
message that pharmacogenomics is helpful
is that patients that were switched off
of medications that had significant
significantly negative Gene drug
interactions showed greater Improvement
and fewer adverse effects than those
that stayed on medications that were not
as genetically appropriate for them
and so to me again showing that by
getting patients off of medications that
are have potential negative Gene drug
interactions we can improve their of the
efficacy and the side effect profile of
our antidepressant medications
um there was another study that looked
at depression in the Community Pharmacy
which I thought was really interesting
and so these were patients that
presented to the Community Pharmacy that
were currently dissatisfied uh with
their depression treatment and were
blinded
um the patients were blinded to their
assignment whether they were on they got
pharmacogenomics or not and what they
found was that patients in the
pharmacogenomics guided group had
greater improvements on the phq-9 which
is a depression questionnaire and the
gad7 which is an anxiety disorder then
those in treatment as usual after six
months
what I think is most interesting about
this study was that prescribers were
more likely to accept recommendations
from the pharmacist when they knew that
PGX was being used versus when they
weren't using the PGX so I thought to me
that to me that was pretty indicative
that you know clinicians do tend to use
pharmacogenomics in a few
pharmacogenomics in a positive light
one additional thing about the study was
that the payer mix did influence the
acceptance of recommendations meaning
that those patients that were more that
had better insurance or more complete
insurance and not through state-funded
Medicaid were actually more likely to
have their clinicians accept the
recommendations for changes in
medications
um I finally I'd like to kind of talk a
little bit about this uh the study that
was done in veterans in VA medical
centers over six months uh with that had
mental illness this was a very large
clinical study that had almost a
thousand patients in both groups there
was pharmacogenomics versus treatment as
usual what they looked at in this study
were the number of Gene drug
interactions and the remission based on
thq9
the study population was mostly white
men with a high prevalence of comor
comorbid PTSD and other anxiety
disorders and 30 of the patients did
have treatment resistant depression but
there was a good representation of
minorities in the study compared to
other studies that have looked at
depression with pharmacogenomics
the outcomes showed that
pharmacogenomics did help to avoid
significant negative Gene drug
interactions so again showing that that
it did work also the pharmacogenomics
harm had a significantly greater rate of
remission over the six-month trial but
after six months there was no difference
between the pharmacogenomic group and
the treatment as usual group and so what
that really means to me is that after
about six months uh you know the
clinicians guessed right on their
patients medications but those that were
Guided by pharmacogenomics got better
quicker and to me that's that's worth
the the use of that just because their
abuse of pharmacogenomics because we're
able to do a lot of
um
getting the patients better faster
the uh also response and rejection and
symptoms severity did favor
pharmacogenomics
um but Pharma a treatment resistant
depression PTSD and race all affected
how high the remission rate was versus
higher high or low based on that so
patients that had higher levels of
comorbid PTSD and were not white had
lower rates of remission
so as I said the pharmacogenomics guided
group did show a faster Mission rate but
true managers will caught up after that
six months
this study did primarily enroll patients
from Psychiatry clinics
um and so that to me says something that
there there are a lot of um studies out
there that look at how farmer are that
uh pcps or Primary Care practitioners
are more likely to benefit from
pharmacogenomics than psychiatrists are
especially in community dwelling
settings
um there was no assessment in the study
of treatment adverse effects and that's
important because one of the big reasons
we do pharmacogenomics is to help
patients not have as many side effects
but this wasn't assessed in this study
also as I mentioned earlier there was a
higher rate of ethnic diversity in this
than other studies and one of the things
that I think about here could be because
a lot of the traditional pharmacogenomic
tests are based on mostly Caucasian data
that this could be a reason why race did
play a role in the remission rates
and so sometimes people think of this as
a potential negative trial for
pharmacogenomics because after six
months there was no difference between
the pharmacogenomics guided group versus
the treatment as usual group but again
as I mentioned I really don't think it
is because what we saw was that the
patients that got pharmacogenomics
guided treatment was were got faster
better so or better faster I should say
uh the last study I'll review as far as
efficacy for
um pharmacogenomics and depression was a
meta-analysis that looked at 13
different trials here uh and all of
these had to be prospective controlled
trials assessing assessing the efficacy
of pharmacogenomics and depression
um in the meta-analysis there was some
bias detected most of these were
industry sponsored potential reporting
bias and performance bias as well but
looking at all 13 of these studies the
relative risk of all trials was 1.41
which basically means that patients were
41 more likely to achieve remission
using pharmacogenomics than they were if
they did use treatment as usual and so
to me that's pretty good data when you
kind of look at all these different
studies taken together you're more
likely to have remission if you use
pharmacologics than if you don't
um and then this study also looked at
that the number of Trials of
antidepressants as the number of
antedipresent Trials increased and the
average depression severity increased so
did the risk ratio in favor of
pharmacogenomics so basically those
patients that have tried and failed a
few different medications and have more
severe depression potentially are more
likely to benefit from pharmacogenomics
I do want to talk about some of the
economic outcomes that have been seen
with depression um and and
pharmacogenomics so
um the reductions in Pharmacy costs over
one year in patients that were General
patients that were depressed
um reduced costs in Primary Care
population and elderly patients and then
there's quite a few cost Effectiveness
models that show that around this around
this number about four thousand dollars
per patient per year savings indirect
and indirect medical costs so to me
that's that's a lot of money to be able
to be saved potentially for our patients
and not only are we saving money for the
Health Care system and for our patients
and providers but we're also helping
them do better clinically
the next set of data that I'd like to
review has to do with what's considered
polypharmacy and polypharmacy really is
the uh meaning that patients are on
multiple medications all at once
this is another place where
pharmacogenomics can be very useful for
a lot of a lot of people
looking at preventing Hospital
admissions the there was a meta-analysis
that was done looking at using five
studies to determine how
pharmacogenomics helped uh
Hospital admissions change over time and
the long and short of it was that there
was about a 50 reduction in Hospital
admissions when pharmacogenomics was
used versus when it wasn't
um and while this isn't really
huge numbers of patients or huge numbers
of studies it kind of does give us a way
to kind of move forward with looking at
more research in this area
the most recent study that actually came
out looking at adverse drug events in
using pharmacogenomics was called the
prepare study this was an open label
trial with crossover design that was
conducted over in um in Europe and there
were almost 7 000 patients enrolled in
this study the primary outcome was
looking at adverse drug events over 12
weeks and they compared PGX to control
patients who were not um
tested at that time whether or not the
clinicians followed the guidelines that
they had been laid out for those
patients using that
um I thought this was interesting that
you know over 93 percent of people that
they studied in this and that they
looked at in the study had at least one
actionable variant so that means when
we're thinking about our patient
population that our patients probably
have you know most of our patients have
some level of actionable variance in
their uh in their genome
and on average patients were on eight
medications together all at once on
average which I think is a pretty good
number there talking about kind of
polypharmacy
um and the most common medication that
initiated the pharmacogenomic testing
was a Statin which is Atorvastatin
followed by Clopidogrel which we talked
about both of those medications
so in the patients that got
pharmacogenomic testing versus those
that did not there were a lower rate of
clinically relevant adverse drug events
leading to an odds ratio of 0.7 which
basically means that there was a 30
reduction in adverse drug events for
those patients that did pharmacogenomics
versus those that did not
um and to me again that's that's a
pretty good number to reduce basically
our adverse drug events by one-third uh
that's that's pretty good data there
uh looking at more uh kind of data
looking at Poly Pharmacy patients um
there was a study that was done looking
at pharmacogenomics as part of a
comprehensive medication Management
program that was implemented in a state
retirement system for Medicare Advantage
patients so this comprehensive
medication management included a review
of lots of different patient factors
lifestyle concomitant medications
illness diet that kind of thing in
addition to their pharmacogenomics and
all that was done by a clinical
pharmacist this medication review and
pharmacogenomics review was discussed
with the patient and then that
recommendations from that
discussion were given to the patient's
provider
in this study over 5000 patients there
was a reduction of about seven thousand
dollars per patient in direct health
care costs compared to non-participants
and that comes out to about 218 dollars
in change per member per month or for
the 32 months of the study it was over
37 almost 37 million dollars
so that's quite a lot of money looking
at the amount of savings that we can get
by in direct health care costs uh here
with this with this outcome and then
looking at Healthcare resource
utilization they did see a reduction in
inpatient visits emergency department
visits and in outpatient visits so
showing that our patients had got better
and saved money in the process
uh and then one study that we did
actually in our own Quest employees uh
was based on that Kentucky teachers
retirement system to study uh we
basically did the same type of of setup
where we had uh comprehensive medication
management with pharmacogenomics
reviewed by a pharmacist uh and then
that was was given to uh the patients
provider this is important because the
previous study they mentioned was all in
65 and older patients we did it in our
employee population which is
significantly younger the average age
here was about 44.
we did an interim analysis and of the
473 patients at this uh
interim analysis that received a
medication action plan they were about
uh average of seven patients breaking
about seven medications and at least
half or over half were taking at least
five medications and what we found was
that 86 percent of patients had an
actionable recommendation and what we
consider an actionable recommendation
was things like providing monitoring
parameters for the patient's current
therapy discontinuing medications or and
starting new medications those were all
kind of actionable recommendations
um the most common medications in our
patient population that had
pharmacogenomic implications were
atorvastatin metformin metoprolol and
bupropion and the reason I brings in
that is just to show that those are some
of the more common medications that we
see in general in the the in all of our
our patients
um and interestingly in those patients
that did have the medication action plan
done
um the average number of pharmacogenomic
medications per patient was between two
and three so that again shows that not
only could it be used for one medication
but these patients were taking lots of
different medications and could
potentially benefit more from the
pharmacogenomic testing because they
were on medications more than the one
medication that they originally did PGX
for
um so to me again that that just shows
that kind of validates some of the data
that has been seen in an older
population but in a younger population
there
um and so I wanted to talk a little bit
about kind of looking into a crystal
ball and figuring out what is the future
of pharmacogenomics look like
um so there are going to be lots of
implementation challenges as we've
already faced um in PGX
um but also opportunities
um a lot of uh clinicians and and
implementers cite education as a barrier
it doesn't have to be a barrier patients
are becoming more and more Savvy and
more and more aware of what
pharmacogenomics can can do for them and
what it is and I often have providers
who are calling me up and are saying hey
my patient brought in this genetic
result and I don't I don't really know
what to what to do with it and so that
to me shows that that patients are
becoming more and more aware of it and
that providers really need to kind of
step up their game if you will
using clinical decision support systems
and EMR alerts can help integrate
pharmacogenomics into practice for some
some of these providers
um one thing that I always hear though
is like you know our interruptive alerts
these these pop-ups are like the bane of
providers existence they just kind of
click through them and so that's why I
kind of said Judas issues only really
when it would be super important for
those would it would it kind of be a
good idea to have those alerts
um and then the alerts though can be
used for if to know whether a patient's
already done pharmacogenomic testing or
whether or not it's appropriate in a
specific circum circumstance to use
pharmacogenomic testing
um and then discrete results meaning
that results that are able to be
downloaded into a cdss or AMR without
being a PDF that lives somewhere in a
lab tab uh on on the EMR is is really
important so that everybody who uses
that EMR or cdss knows that this patient
has pharmacogenomics results for them
the other thing here is that pharmacists
are some of the most accessible
Healthcare professionals and they are
met at Pharmacists are the medication
experts right but when I think back to
when I went to school I'm not going to
say how many years ago but when I went
to school former coach genomics was
really not a big part of my education as
a pharmacist and so it's really
important that we do some of these
educational
presentations and and CE continuing
educations that kind of thing for
pharmacists so that everybody can be on
the same level when it comes to
pharmacogenomic status pharmacists like
I said are the medication experts the um
other issue that I hear is that well
this is a once in a lifetime test right
well it is right because your genes
don't ever really change
um but how do you get those that
information from one person one Health
System to the next Health System
um and to make sure that that provider
that new provider knows that there was
pharmacogenomics done and as I say there
emrs are great but they are very health
system specific and that is
um can be a problem when you are you
have a patient who moves cities or towns
or or States even
patients should become the Guardians of
their own data and one thing that they
did that I thought was really cool in
the prepare trial was that
um they used a QR code that anybody if
they patient presented this card with
the QR code any provider could scan it
and then find out what that patient's
genetics genetic results were and to me
that's really cool technology to be able
to do that and and you know is that
something that can be replicated I'd
love to see that see if it can be done
uh here in the U.S
um one other thing is to make sure that
providers are asking if pharmacogenomics
have been done in the past some patients
may not know that they had it done
um but it never hurts to ask the
question
uh one other thing that can be
challenging is changing provi provider
behaviors
um and and attitudes
um you know when I first started uh in
the pharmacogenomics area about 10 or 11
years ago
um what I was hearing then was well what
I do now works for my patients really
well and and and
so I don't really need to use
pharmacogenomics I don't I don't think
that it's worthwhile
um but now what I'm saying is Well I
don't use it because I don't think the
data is as good as it seems
um so there's always resistance to new
technologies and I feel like there are
ways that we can kind of combat that
resistance one is to not necessarily
scare providers obviously but to talk
about the legal liability
um that could potentially have a problem
um with uh former not doing
pharmacogenomics in fact there was a
organ
health system that uh ended up being
sued for dpyd not using a specific Gene
to help guide chemotherapy for a patient
uh and so those are kind of some
examples that we can use
um the pharmacogenomics not being
included in specific guidelines can be a
problem
um because it leads to clinicians
discounting their benefit
the benefit of pharmacogenomics oh it's
not in the guidelines so why would I
want to do it right
um and but
um you know just because something's not
in specific guidelines doesn't mean it
can't be useful
the other thing I think that really is
important are multiple Edition
multiplicity teams are needed to Aid in
especially larger Health Systems so we
need a coalition of of different
disciplines pharmacists nursing
physician Champions to kind of be able
to get pharmacogenomics accepted in
health systems and the best way I've
seen that done is kind of starting small
so looking at a you know one specific
Gene drug interaction for instance and
then kind of expanding from there once
that's been kind of more widely accepted
um and as we saw in some of the clinical
studies that I reviewed pharmacists
doing
um using cdss software can translate a
lot of the quote unquote mumbo jumbo
that clinicians feel like
pharmacogenomics is into clinical action
um and then
um if there is a really long turnaround
time between the time when the patient
was you know the sample was taken versus
when they get the results back uh that
can limit its usefulness uh and then one
of the other big things that I always
get asked is
um you know well you know how much does
this cost right and so currently you
know there are a lot of
um barriers potentially there for for us
um but it doesn't have to be a barrier
um so commercial payer acceptance has
been traditionally
um or historically very very slow here
um everybody wants more data
um and for clinical and economic
outcomes and you know the gold standard
of randomized placebo-controlled Trials
aren't necessarily feasible for some of
these
um you know pharmacogenomic panels or
even ethical depending on what we're
looking at here and so that that makes
it difficult they want to see uh
commercial payers generally want to see
uh return on investment or Roi within a
year
um and so the best way I feel like to be
able to do that is to use algorithms to
stratify patients that are most likely
to benefit from pharmacogenomics so that
we're only testing those patients that
are likely to benefit right we're not
just testing everybody all the time but
really only those patients that are most
likely to benefit and as we saw again in
some of the clinical studies I presented
employer-sponsored testing can be a
proven strategy to help kind of
achieve positive Health Care outcomes
while also achieving positive economic
outcomes
and then
currently now pharmacogenomic panels are
reimbursed for mental health reasons but
single Gene tests tend to have better
reimbursement on a uh one by one basis
as we saw in the studies that I
presented most patients have at least
one actionable pharmacogenomic variant
that could impact medication outcomes
but one of the things we have to think
about here is allele frequencies are
vary based on the patient population
that we're talking about various
ethnicities races all of that kind of
stuff
can be you know an issue here because a
lot of the research that's been done has
not been done in a diverse population
so to conclude
pharmacogenomic guidelines do exist and
they are held for very high evidentiary
standard pharmacogenomics is a very very
valuable tool that does improve clinical
and economic outcomes in patients that
have depression and inpatients that are
receiving multiple medications
uh and then as I just discussed when
implementing pharmacal genomics it can
be difficult
um but there are ways that we can
overcome some of those barriers
and that I'll I'll stop and we'll enter
our q a session
thank you Dr Lorenz for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar now to our
audience
the end and questions you would like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay Dr Lorenz let's get
started now we have quite a few
questions coming in but I would like to
start with this one
let's
what is classified as adverse drug
effects
so that's a really good question so
adverse drug effects are anything that
is not what we want the drug or the
medication to be doing
um and so that includes adverse drug
reactions
um or you know as we call side effects
those kinds of things so anything that
happens that we don't want to happen
um because uh that patient was taking
that medication and they can be as
um you know as minimal as like
nauseousness all the way up to and
including potential death depending on
what medications we're talking about
here and so there is a wide range there
of looking at what is considered an
adverse drug effect but in general again
it's those things that happen when a
patient takes a medication that we don't
want to happen
for clarifying that our next question
where do you see pharmacogenomics being
most useful
so another really good question I think
pharmacogenomics is most useful in those
patients kind of that I was talking
about earlier in patients that have um
you know significant depression
especially uh in those patients that
potentially are taking lots of different
medications but also in your primary
care practitioner office they have the
potential to be prescribing lots of
different medications that have
pharmacogenomic implications and so
using pharmacogenomics in the primary
care clinic can be really really helpful
for multiple areas of the patient's
therapy
thank you our next question
when assessing which alleles to test for
in a PGX panel what considerations do
you have
so the alleles testing in a specific
pharmacogenomic panel obviously depend
on which genes we're going to be looking
at
um but there are lists of what are
considered quote unquote recommended or
tier one uh alleles that need to be
tested for for various different genes
so definitely we want to include those
at a minimum but in my mind more is is
usually better and so the more alleles
that we're looking for the less likely
it is that with the testing will result
to a default of normal because that is
that is the default so if we have
patients that have very or more rare
variants as far as their alleles are
concerned in a specific Gene
um then they're much more likely and if
you're only looking for a very minimum
amount of alleles to come up as normal
when they may not be normal and so that
that to me is why more is better
um and I feel like two you know if we
are trying to give patients the benefit
of the doubt and increase our
um
diversity in our patients then we are
going to see a lot more of these rare
variants out there than we would than we
normally do see
thank you Dr Lorenz this question next
has come in a few times why does
medication management by pharmacists
utilizing pharmacogenomics testing
improve outcomes
so yeah that's a really good question
and I feel like it does kind of bear a
little bit more a deeper dive if you
will
um and I think it's it's they're
multifaceted really right so as I
mentioned during the presentation
pharmacists are the medication experts
right they're we're the ones that go to
schools to learn about medications right
so we should know all of that
information
um and then by an extension of that
pharmacogenomics is a great tool that we
can use to supplement all of that
knowledge that we already have about how
medications work and you know when to
use them when not to use them all of
that stuff to be able to pinpoint which
patients are going to benefit or have
fewer side effects to certain
medications and so I think that by
looking at the patient as a whole as
pharmacists are trained to do and not
just looking at one specific drug one
specific Gene interaction that is kind
of why I think Pharmacists and and this
you know using PGX do does improve
outcomes greater than just doing
pharmacogenomics off the top without
using pharmacist intervention
and Joshua Lawrence we have time for one
more question we'll wrap with things
with things says would you recommend
attending to learn more about
pharmacogenomics
so there's lots of different
um uh you know conferences that are out
there cpic does do a conference every
two years that's a really great
opportunity University of Florida also
has a Precision medicine meeting as well
usually once uh every year every or
every two years
the Mayo Clinic has some some meetings
as well University of Minnesota I'm sure
there's a bunch that I'm that I'm
missing but there are really good places
where you can kind of get
to meet other people who are interested
in pharmacogenomics and get you know
kind of The Cutting Edge knowledge there
for you some of the bigger National
meetings also do have some components of
pharmacogenomics if you look at the
various Specialties like obviously
oncology has
um you know lots of of continuing
education that's out there in meetings
regarding um you know pharmacogenomics
for chemotherapy and then also looking
at different you know in mental health
and in Dermatology there's lots of
places but there's usually not at these
larger meetings it's very sub it's very
uh specialized and so
um you know if you want a broader
pharmacogenomic education go into one of
those other meetings would be really
really good
thank you again Dr Lorenz for your time
today and for your important research do
you have any final comments for our
audience
no I just want to thank you guys for
inviting me to talk and I hope everybody
learned something today
thank you now we'd also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I do
want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions those questions we weren't
able to answer today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration today's webcast can be
viewed on demand and labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now thanks for joining us and
have a great day